and that's why I believe the importance
of like security and all that [ __ ]
because I'm paranoid bro everywhere I go
I've always been paranoid and I'm kind
of like
easing out of it now you know yeah but
you ease out of it and then you see you
ease out of it you see uh when your
comrades lose their life when they let
their Garden they snap you right back
into it that's what I'm saying and I'm
glad you made that point because you
ease out of it the more you experience
life the more you see stuff the more you
were able to travel the more you're able
to make money like I was afraid for my
life in Chicago I moved to LA to get
away from that [ __ ] right and then you
see somebody that you love pnb Long Live
my brother that's what I'm talking about
I love I love pnb you see these things
nip all these people you know what I'm
saying I came here to get away from this
[ __ ] and then you like oh [ __ ] they're
still like that out here but at the end
of the day it's like that everywhere
this is everywhere no matter where you
are anywhere in another country yeah
it's like that everywhere you know what
I'm saying so the realization of it is
you can't put your guard down so how do
you deal with it you know so like I I
also think that like you just have to
kind of understand who you are exactly
you're G herbo so you're not gonna like
you're gonna take notes if you're if
you're self-aware and you're sure of
yourself I think there's certain ways
you can move around or if like
absolutely if you get caught slipping
like you want my like you want my iPhone
I'll believe it go ahead take it I'll
believe it I'm that type of guy I say
that all the time I look at the camera
and say that I don't have no ego it's
not no
Gangsta bone in my body that's gonna
feel funny about like I I understand
that you know I'm saying God forbid if
I'm ever in that situation my pride will
never get in the way of me getting back
home family period ever ever ever you
could have that [ __ ] you want the car
I'll give you my car go ahead take it I
got an insurance
get away from me it's gonna be the most
calm robbery and it's not gonna be it's
gonna be don't touch me don't touch me
don't put your hands on me don't harm my
fat don't do nothing you can have this
[ __ ] man this [ __ ] ain't nothing it
ain't worth it it ain't never worth it I
could get it again you need it more than
a million more times you could have this
[ __ ] bro you can have my car you have
everything huh you need to get away car
take this [ __ ]